nous allons accueillir sur scène celui
qui a rassemblé notre famille politique
le président des républicains Monsieur
Christian Jacob
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci merci mes amis
merci à tous
merci merci ma chère Rachida pour tes
mots pour ton accueil et puis pour ta
capacité à une email débat public parce
que une campagne sans Rachida c'est
quand même pas pareil
j'oublie pas du cerf moment des
municipales et c'était pas facile pour
nous parce que c'était au lendemain des
européennes lorsqu'on sillonnaient la
France pour aller soutenir nos candidats
et à chaque fois on me disait quand même
Rachida à Paris elle est en train de
créer une dynamique et tu as créer une
dynamique au moment des au moment des
municipales je voudrais maintenant vous
adresser m'adresser à vous tous vous
président de fédération secrétaire
départementaux délégué de
circonscription
RDJ vous avez été depuis toujours de
toutes les batailles vous avez été
remarquable mais plus que ça vous avez
été solide dans les moments difficiles
vous savez un arbre pour qu'il résiste
période de sécheresse au coup de vent
aux habits de tempête il faut qu'il est
un solide enracinement vous êtes ses
racines
peut-être qu'on vous a jamais traité de
Racine mais de la part d'un paysan
croyez-moi c'est un compliment
[Rires]
je voudrais aussi remercier tous nos
permanent un certain nombre sont ici les
permanents du siège l'ensemble des
salariés de la rue de Vaugirard ils ont
été là aussi notamment ces derniers
jours à l'occasion de la préparation du
congrès d'une mobilisation
extraordinaire certains entre eux c'est
quasiment jour et nuit qu'ils ont qu'ils
ont été là pour que tout se passe bien
et tout s'est bien passé c'est aussi
l'occasion de les remercier
tu vois ma chère Valérie nous avons un
parti qui est aujourd'hui totalement
mobilisés en ordre de bataille pas en
ordre de marche parce que ce sera pas
une promenade de santé
et si notre famille à cette expérience
expérience et moins qu'on puisse dire
des des difficultés on a aussi toujours
su démontrer que baisser les bras
laisser tomber c'était pas dans notre
nature c'était pas dans notre culture et
une fois de plus c'est grâce à toi on
est en train de le démontrer
depuis 2 ans le chemin n'a pas n'a pas
été facile mais nous avons tout gagné
nous avons gagné les municipales les
sénatoriales les départementales les
régionales à chaque fois on a fait
mordre la poussière à nos adversaires
mais aussi à tous les pronostiqueurs de
malheur qui systématiquement sur obligé
d'avancer notre défaite passe pas à
démarrer une campagne électorale
autrement que comme ça et si nous avons
réussi tu réussis depuis 2 ans c'est
pour deux raisons d'abord pour les
collectivités territoriales parce que on
a su montrer notre capacité à gérer et
puis on a su le faire dans l'unité dans
le rassemblement c'est ça qui nous
amener à chaque fois à la victoire et on
l'a vu dans les différentes
collectivités que je viens d'évoquer est
de la même façon que le le rassemblement
ne se décrète pas il se construit papa
et j'en sais un peu quelque chose le
président de la République
président de la République on le voit de
plus 10 ans maintenant ça ne s'improvise
pas on a eu deux présidents de la
République successifs qui se sont
improviser et ça ne s'improvise pas
c'est l'aboutissement d'un chemin tracé
par l'envie par la compétence par
l'expérience par le talent tu as tout
cela Valérie tu as tout cela et ça se
sont d'abord certes tes qualités
personnelles mais aussi des expériences
de parlementaires de ministre dans des
postes difficile et exposés et aussi ta
capacité à diriger la plus grande
collectivité de France et c'est tout
cela qui fait que tu es là où tu es
aujourd'hui bravo merci
le président sortant ne pourra pas
continuer longtemps à cacher son bilan
est catastrophique
derrière un écran de fumée prenons
l'exemple Rachida prenez quelques
exemples tout à l'heure pendant celui
des dépenses publiques et dépenses
publiques après la crise de 2008 et Dieu
sait que c'est crise financière avait
été difficile et je le dis devant devant
François Baroin c'était maman compliqué
à gérer au lendemain de cette crise de
2008 les dépenses publiques augmenter
d'un pour 100 parents ensuite avec
François Hollande ils ont augmenté d'à
peu près un an et demi pour cent parents
et puis c'est Emmanuel Macron et je
parle avant le covit bien évidemment
on est à 2,6 parents 2,6 parents comme
Valérie disons cramer la caisse ils ont
effectivement cramé la caisse c'est les
mots qui conviennent
sur les trois derniers exercices que
nous venons de voter au Parlement sur
les budgets
2020-2021 2022 en dehors de tout plan de
relance bien entendu on extrait de cela
toutes les dépenses liées au covit là
aussi c'est 100 milliards d'euros de
dépenses publiques supplémentaires les
amis quand quelqu'un se revendique de la
droite le moins que je puisse qu'on
puisse dire c'est que ça n'est pas la
nôtre de droite ça n'est pas la droite
de la gestion rigoureuse ça n'est pas la
droite attentive aux dépenses publiques
et Eaubonne équilibre du budget c'est
exactement l'inverse et c'est exemple je
prends sur le sur le budget on peut les
prendre dans tous les domaines sur la
sécurité concernant les violences aux
personnes sur ce seul sujet des
violences aux personnes depuis l'arrivée
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est 20 %
d'augmentation des violences faites aux
personnes sur l'immigration Rachida il
faisait et écho tout à l'heure depuis
l'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron dans tous
les domaines les titres de séjour Basile
les mineurs non accompagnés tous les
chiffres explose sur l'international que
ce soit avec Donald Trump avec Maiden
avec Salvini avec Erdogan avec Boris
Johnson à chaque fois c'est la même
chose on va d'arrogance en coup de
menton et à l'arrivée il n'y a jamais de
résultat jamais de résultat sur la scène
internationale souvenez-vous de
l'emprise qu'avait est Jacques Chirac
est Nicolas Sarkozy lorsqu'il était en
fonction nous avions une France et un
président qui faisait rayonner la France
aujourd'hui on est bien loin de tout
cela sur la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique là aussi pas de
vision pas de stratégie d'écoute comme
surlendemain vous savez avec avec
Emmanuel Macron
maintenant la méthode on l'a on l'a
connaît
je ne suis pas un danseur émérite mais
je peux vous dire que c'est une valse à
trois temps c'est un j'annonce deux je
renonce et 3 le pays s'enfonce c'est ça
la réalité de maintenant
tu te moques pas Rachida
[Applaudissements]
nous avons
depuis depuis 2 ans bâti un projet pour
la France bâti un socle idéologique sur
lequel nos candidats au Congrès se sont
retrouvés et je voudrais comme l'a fait
Rachid à tout à l'heure les saluer pour
leur dire la formidable images qu'ils
ont donné de notre famille politique et
qu'ils ont su donné aux Français nous
avons et ils ont démontré qu'il y avait
aujourd'hui à droite une équipe de
France qui était prête que tu es prête à
gouverner et je voudrais qu'on les
applaudissent bien fort tout d'abord
Éric notre finaliste et puis Michel
Xavier Philippe vous avez été formidable
vous avez donné une image excellente
les Français ont compris qu'avec
Emmanuel Macron c'était le pouvoir de
faire semblant faire semblant de
réformer faire semblant de tranchée
faire semblant d'être deux droites faire
semblant d'agir faire semblant d'être
européen sur une chaise
toi Valérie au moins tu fais pas
semblant
tu ne fais pas semblant d'être de droite
et moi qui te connais comme président de
région quand tu diriges s région
Île-de-France tu ne fais pas semblant
non plus de diriger tu l'as vraiment
je ne parle pas de décliniste de rentrer
les vers qui veulent nous ramener à
l'éclairage à la bougie entre Zemmour
qui rêve des années 30 entre Le Pen qui
est dans un bateau qui prend l'eau 104
les boussoles tous ont un point commun
tous il regarde l'avenir dans un
rétroviseur il regarde derrière tous les
soirs
nous sommes les seuls à la carnet cet
espoir et si nous avions besoin d'une
démonstration tu viens nous l'a donné
Valérie avec la dynamique que tu viens
de créer dans le pays depuis 8 jours
vous avez vu ce qui change ça change et
ça n'est pas bien entendu chez nous tant
que militant ça c'était une évidence
mais c'est bien au-delà le peuple de
droite se réveille les Français
reprennent espoir le match de se
déroulera pas comme il avait imaginé et
comme tous les éditorialistes nous
l'avait raconté il y a un espoir qui est
né avec ta candidature les Français la
droite tout le monde se réveille et
crois-moi je suis convaincu de va voir
les choses s'accentuer dans les jours
qui viennent
alors je voudrais
j'avais prévu de la bouche applaudissent
et c'est pour ça que j'ai du mal à
tourner mes pages et
[Applaudissements]
les Français ont compris que notre
victoire était possible nous avons un
projet nous avons une équipe je viens de
l'évoquer nous avons plus de la moitié
des des collectivités territoriales
nous avons 150000 militants répartis
ancrée surtout notre territoire nous
avons un grand mouvement de jeunesse
restructurer dynamique et je voudrais
saluer Guilhem Carayon là aussi les
jeunes ont été formidable dans 700 Paris
alors maintenant les amis
scie sabre au clair et en avant dans
toutes les fédérations dans toutes les
conceptions dans tous les cantons dans
toutes les villes dans tous les villages
il y a eu le temps des analyses le temps
des débats le temps des discussions ce
temps maintenant il est terminée nous
sommes en campagne avec un seul objectif
celui de gagner et s'il y a un message
et ce sera mon mot de conclusion je
voulais t'adresser Valérie c'est te dire
et tu es bien placé pour le savoir quand
Jacques Chirac gagnant 95 c'est parce
que il est lui-même quand Nicolas
Sarkozy gagne en 2007 c'est parce que il
est lui-même alors Valérie sois toi-même
et tu nous amènera la victoire
merci
le président
[Applaudissements]